c'est de récupérer le fond je n'ai pas
encore parfaite mobilité de la cheville
alors j'essaie de courir à mon rythme
puis de récupérer 20 dans le fond elle
est ferme à rélégation pour la suisse ce
matin vous avez trottiner alors contre
ça s'est passé
bah ça se passe bien sauf quand on
m'avait pris là parce qu'elle était
froid alors je boîtier un tout petit peu
or après le footing
j'ai fait une demi heure avec bernard
menez diaby qui n'est pour retrouver les
appeler est-ce que vous souffrez anglo
cette cheville on s'offrirait je suis un
peu comme les personnes âgées je sais
quand on peut voir parce que j'ai
beaucoup de rhumatismes alors fin
janvier il ya une grande tournée au
mexique est ce que vous en ferez partie
ben je pense j'ai posé confirmation la
part de monsieur punis mais je penserai
participé du mec de même que merchadier
mais en soi le soir après 7 heures après
cette remise en jambes alors qu'elle est
le point de vue du spécialiste mais je
pense que pour michel tout va très bien
actuellement
il a retrouvé une grande partie de ses
moyens peut-être pas physique en
finlande un pays qui veut dire condition
physique il en est à peu près qu'à 50%
au niveau de son intégrité fonctionnel
niveau de la cheville je pense qu'il est
à 60 70 % de ses possibilités
actuellement non ce qui surprend les
néophytes c'est la relative rapidité de
la remise en pièces que c'est relative
toute relative ça fait déjà trois mois
que des blessés de toute façon une
fracture au niveau de la cheville mais
un peu moins de temps qu une fracture du
tibia et du péroné
pourquoi en parler mais je pense qu'ils
tout à fait dans les normes et qui a
aucun problème
penser qu'il sera prêt pour le 28
janvier on l'espère surtout on espère
surtout et l'attrait le voyage que nous
devons faire aux états unis
et où on emmènera michel nous renforcera
dans cette opinion pas suivant le
résultat des matches amicaux qu'il fera
là bas optimiste optimiste oui